I think marriage as an institution works
but the problem is the way they do it
today just doesn't work women are
different today than they were in the
1950s so what you're not the same type
of women and essentially what was my age
for like when you got married you were
getting married to a virgin that's the
whole white dressing right you'll be
hard-pressed to find a virgin woman
nowadays
so a man knows that he was going to get
this woman untouched and she was going
to be his for Life yeah you ain't
getting all Untouchable nowadays that's
the thing if a woman slept with if she's
a virgin she has an 80 chance of having
a happy marriage in 10 years if she
slept with more than five Partners which
most men would pray for nowadays it goes
down to it goes down to a 20 chance so
women are different than they were in
the 1950s